[Music]
people are going to be isolated right
now and feeling really alone we'd be
talking about 1.2 billion pounds worth
of loss it's merely about people coming
together at a time like this you don't
rise how much family means to you until
you know with them the spring of 2020
won't be remembered for their glorious
weather in the UK it'll be remembered
for a nation in lockdown all over the UK
people are coping with a fundamental
change to their daily lives adapting in
difficult times to this new normal has
been challenging for us all a sense of
isolation even when going out for
essentials or a daily walk we've been
reporting from around the UK on how the
countries dealing with life in lockdown
first let's take you to Cornwall where
our West of England correspondent Dan
Whitehead has this report
newland harbor at the southern tip of
corn Lou these trawlers usually land
fish that ends up in the world's finest
restaurants but no more as soon as the
pandemic reached reached a point where
borders were being closed through the
fishing industry that was stopped from
that moment jeremy Hosken is a
third-generation fisherman he should be
out catching lobster and crab as little
boats were just started in our season
we've just been through a really poor
winter we haven't learnt very much four
five or six months we're just about to
begin what we would normally expect do
and obviously this pandemic has has come
right at that moment so we've gone a
long period of time with the with no
income and now we've got another period
that we really don't know where the
incomes going to come from usually this
is one of the UK's busiest fishing ports
but it's dead there are very few boats
operational and without the restaurants
and the associated trade this industry
is becoming increasingly impossible but
there is a glimmer of hope is pandemic
has actually created a new opportunity
for Cornwall's fishermen well this is
turret from newly market this morning
kasia's payne says the virus stopped his
business overnight he needed to act
quickly
the Cornish fish produces organization
launched fish to your door and the
orders just keep on coming well we get
in families audio and direct to the
house people are starting to cooking
again you know and those back to basics
basically what we was doing years ago
you know get rid of all these ready
meals its proper home food good
wholesome food fresh straight from the
sea next day within 24 hours it's at
your house while some can adapt others
have been forced to close
Padstow on the north coast
this holiday whether it should be packed
it looks and sounds like never before
right across Cornwall the Sun is out but
the county is deserted
what would the part normally be like
full of joy full of children running
around having a great time
shows characters different life the
camel Creek Adventure Park has
furloughed around 130 staff usually
they've been looking after 3,000
visitors a day there is no one playing
there is no laughter there are no
memories being made it is eerie isn't it
have you ever seen it like this no of
course not not even during the winter
not even during the refurbishing time we
would have staff members everywhere
painting brushing cleaning getting the
park ready so it's it's very very
strange it feels abandoned and it's like
this at attractions across the county
all they could do is prepare and hope
it's really is about making sure we got
a plan a and a plan B and Plan C for any
eventuality as to when the park will be
reopened and last when the world's will
start to to be relaxed it's real isn't
it it is Aurilia yeah it is daunting
at this time of year tourism would see
Cornwall's population increase by around
a third that this virus shut the
industry down all agree the lockdown is
essential there is a greater fear
tourists must return for July and August
the peak months and there's a stark
warning if they can't for the worst-case
scenario which we hope will never happen
this went through to to August we've
been talking about 1.2 billion pounds
worth of loss and that will that will be
the end for some it was according to our
research at the end of 80 percent of the
businesses there should be thousands of
holidaymakers here right now enjoying
this site but it's locked down it is
empty there is nobody here this is the
biggest test for Cornwall's tourism
sector but even in this adversity sites
like this and doing what they can to
help those on the front line
Hendra Holiday Park in Newquay is making
its caravans available to key workers
who need to isolate holiday let's across
the county are being offered up Hannah
Dobson is a care worker that calls only
major hospital both her parents a
classed as vulnerable and it's just 18
she decided to move out of home for the
first time she was given a holiday cabin
by a local family I've been completely
used to just being all like mom and dad
can do my washing and things like that
and not having to go like from having it
one week and then the next week
completely you are on your own now I'm
kind of like learning with it now but
yeah it's
I'm so grateful for the accommodation
that I've been given like so so so
grateful that I'm able to still work and
my parents are safe as well
the coronavirus has left Cornwall empty
and silent
for many all they can do is wait
the tourists will return the beaches
will be full again but the fear is it
could be too late for some Dan Whitehead
reporting there well the Blitz spirit
championed by the wartime generation
during this pandemic is felt though more
strongly than in Coventry a city that's
no stranger to crisis our correspondent
Mark Stone reports on the sense of help
and hope in the Midlands
in the heart of Britain there is a place
where they know a thing or two about
resilience about community spirit one
quote from the picking show it's 9:00 in
the morning on who knows what day four
the volunteers of this Food Bank each
seems to roll into the other at the
moment we're in Coventry in a warehouse
where two organizations have come
together the Trussell Trust is used to
getting food out to those who can't
afford it but now as well they must get
it to those two vulnerable to leave
their homes the donations are sorted
boxed loaded and away
the destination is across the city the
good neighbors project is the initiative
of an organization called simply hope
the volunteers here are in full swing
they've been in overdrive since the
lockdown began what's driven you to come
down here and help out
The Voice got me involved so I thought
why not well give more time or I'll give
my tamil to help people with a system
they call hub-and-spoke they fan out
into the city a lot of parcels to be
delivered today and can I call you back
I'm just dropping off some food at the
moment this is Jackie
on her way to deliver a food parcel to a
man called Ali to everybody around the
country or who is watching this thanks
ever so much for helping people like
myself and other vulnerable people
during this difficult time up the road
the police are out what a sign of these
Korona times this is nada Raza has a
wife and three children to support in
lockdown at home and he has three
employees to support at his shop which
must remain open because he has a
community to provide for and a living to
make these are the multi-layered
conundrums of this challenging time then
maybe next week we end up than this one
we disclose the old cathedral stands
here as a memorial of the Blitz
destroyed on one night of bombing in
1940 they thought it would break the
spirit of the city instead the opposite
happened out of this came hope it stands
still as a reminder of survival and of
renewal linking those past struggles
with today is that perhaps somehow not
quite the appropriate comparison well
the community spirit and the
determination
which rose from here back then is
without question here again today in
abundance the human desire for company
for being together for supporting each
other for being supported by others is
so deep and so powerful that it's
finding a way of overcoming the distance
which has been enforced upon us by this
virus I think in wartime you had the
same sort of experience we're having
today
a deep desire for connectedness for
togetherness a spirit of help I would
put it realizing in the city and also a
spirit of hope on the road south Chris
Merrett is keeping food shops in the
smaller town stocked delivery drivers
have always been key it's just that now
they are recognized we drive past now we
get the thumbs up from people we get
people Pippin you know so you know it's
a privilege Chris's route takes him
through a place where lock downs and
pandemics have been part of history
stratford-upon-avon shakespeare's
birthplace quiet and shut today just
like it was 500 years ago because an
outbreak of the plague began here in
this in the first victim Oliver Gunn
died inside his death certificate
carries the words here begins the plague
it's in a registry office that today is
only open for people to register the
dead
on the edge of the town at the
Shakespeare Hospice Jenna Norris is one
of a team of palliative care nurses
comforting those at the end of their
life well we're just following Nurse
Jenna now as she begins her day of home
visits it's gonna be a long day for her
and for many others and it's occurred to
me that as we as a society have focused
a lot on hospitals we focus less on
nurses who are making these
all-important home visits as a
palliative care nurse and we're normally
very tactile with our patients and their
families and we use touch a lot as a
method of comfort so for example like
you said giving someone a hug or hold in
their hand and not being able to do that
at the moment is really really hard down
on the Aven this was supposed to be the
setting for a big Easter fundraiser for
the struggling Hospice of course that
didn't happen
Nick birch organizer of the fundraiser
an owner of even boating has furloughed
all his staff we meet on what should be
the first week of his tourist season
instead now he's wondering what next we
were all concerned about the business
and the outcome and a lot of unknowns at
this point how long it's going to go on
how long we can maintain our reserves
what we will need to borrow how much and
when and how much that will cost a lot
of unknowns that no but you've got to
take it bit by bit keep a stiff upper
lip I suppose
further south Shakespeare's country
gives way to the Cotswolds and fields
farmed by four brothers from an old
family of vegetable growers that drink
waters they have never known it so busy
from the farm shop a home delivery
service has been set up in just days
hello there I would shake your hand but
we can't we can't how are you I'm Marc a
local family supporting the local
community with local produce the world
will never be the same again after
Corona and I think people there are some
fantastic ideas out there where if we
ever get over this which we will the
world has to change I look at life
differently now to what I did six weeks
ago it's made me realize actually what I
have here baby
the coronavirus will actually some good
of it will come in the end and it will
make people realize the fact that we
have to look after the planet for not
only for our children for Fred
children's children Mark Stone reporting
there Walter Scotland and the largest
arts festival in the world the Edinburgh
Fringe it faces a loss of at least 300
million pounds after being canceled our
Scotland correspondent James Matthews
reports on fundraising football and
family
[Music]
central Edinburgh at 7:00 a.m. the no
rush it's the lost city look in a city
with a lot to lose 300 million pounds
for starters because this year the
summer festivals are canceled mark
Nelson cue comedy from the front room
it's gonna devastate the catering
community it's gonna devastate the hotel
industry and Edinburgh it's gonna
absolutely decimate the cocaine industry
and a lot of the UK as well The Stand
comedy club is among those improving a
live stream alternative showbiz survival
for artists without the world's biggest
arts festival as the most important
thing we have and yeah it's like our
Super Bowl once one finishes you start
saying about the next one and then you
start right in the shore and then if
it's two months of previews to floor
that so it has kind of a culmination of
a whole years worth of work so it's a
big deal for it not to be happening
[Music]
in Cromartie dr. Catherine Brown new
plays for patients musical therapy even
in two pairs of protective gloves this
Highlands GP has walked around the world
and has known disaster by the
Christchurch earthquake in New Zealand
what she saw then is in keeping with
what she sees now it's mainly about
people coming together at a time like
this within healthcare profession with
the healthcare profession and members of
the community rallying together to help
out in a real time of crisis your people
in Scotland have died from coronavirus
than previously thought as our daily
briefing Nicola Sturgeon sister change
in the we feel like this is touch words
I hope as close to situation to military
being called to services I might ever
get to but because we are on the front
line but on the front line in a medical
sense can you see and hear me okay I
think it helps me remind myself I am a
human being and and I don't always have
the answers and I think to be honest
certainly working in general practice
would you work with a lot of uncertainty
are you using the zoom or what but this
is this is learning to deal with
uncertainty on a different basis all
together you know and something that
like I say none of us will ever come
across before in this crisis of life and
death foodborne is less important but
it's life and death is an issue meat
Raith Rovers fan roaring it's a way that
you still connect with friends and also
family Margie
I've got a self under weird there are
weird and if we keep winning our key
will not say too much games and grill
that's all we people have some people to
come here that starts part the rumors
aren't as vulnerable as some but listen
to their Chairman's prognosis for
Scottish football
without gate receipts I would suspect
that there's at least half a dozen clubs
that would be facing going into
receivership or administration whatever
you want to call it in about three four
or five months time and how Scottish
football would recover from now I don't
know
Rory's launched on donate a ticket
scheme were fans donate the price of a
ticket for a game they won't watch but
for teams they'll help survive some of
the best moments of my life will be
supporting Raith Rovers it's just a
massive part of your life and it would
be sorely missed I didn't realize how
much Saturday's Maine to me and know
that Saturday's just the same as every
other day Scott Schreiber goes deeper
than just Rangers and Celtic that's
clubs like Stenhousemuir and barek
Rangers Queens Park these guys have had
massive massive inputs into the game in
Scotland which is you know a cornerstone
of Scottish culture back in Edinburgh I
went to the city's Marie Curie hospice
where social distancing has made its
annual daffodil appeal and possible
they're seeking emergency donations
it's a financial hit
adding to emotional impact on a place
that treats people with terminal illness
especially Angela McLaughlin's husband
and two daughters aren't able to pay her
a visit
coronavirus precautions forbidden 10:14
and and it's been hard to name as we
have not been able to see me cookie
we're doing FaceTime but it's not a same
you want a cuddle from here they made a
decision from day one to prevent the
experience of so many casualties of this
pandemic with precautions they time one
final family visit so that no one dies
alone if we can give that comfort to
families then that makes a difference
because conversely we know the
people aren't there and can't see and
therefore it's their imagination then
that's when they start being tortured by
it in weeks and months and sometimes
even years to come so this really
matters on life and death the other
rules rewritten James Matthews reporting
there well a life on hold means dreams
of success in sport or music are being
extinguished our rich cultural heritage
with an uncertain future our north of
England correspondent Katarina Batak see
reports
this was supposed to be Liverpool's year
at 25 points clear a Premier League win
and victory parade along these streets
seemed inevitable
[Applause]
and then came covert 19 it put the
season and the dreams of millions on
hold but it can't stop everything baby
Mel is nine days old born into a crisis
she won't remember
no one's called about two days
afterwards
it was dad come fast look through the
window and have to meet her through the
window and you think after we'd gone I
cried that's the first time I cries and
I thought that's not how life should be
when you've got a new baby
Vikki is an NHS midwife her family have
been desperate to see the baby but to
protect her colleagues still at work
she's kept grandparents out party when
it's all the boundaries they're gonna
have a party awfully you say you know
you're gonna have big street parties but
are people going to do that because is
it good to be in the back of mind that
it's still not completely gone that in
the back of my mind is it are you going
to get massive gatherings again straight
away I don't think I don't think you
will this outbreak has forced people
apart well being that's not to brake the
wheels and social distancing this
weekend as is expected to get up to 18
degrees across the northwest in
Stockport on the outskirts of Manchester
this is how Andrew bowel doc is coping a
one-off outing dress like this has
become a daily routine
and a daily highlight for bored
neighbors some have even joined in and
that includes the man under the mask I
was having some low days I mean I
actually suffer from depression and
anxiety so obviously at the beginning
before I started doing this it was
rather difficult but seeing people come
together laughing joking waving it's
somewhat lifting and that has really
helped me as well so we're all getting a
little bit of something out of it that
sense of coming together as helping
people survive this uniting communities
even those deeply divided after brexit
across the Pennine in the Northeast
Sunderland was a city torn into between
those who wanted to stay in the EU are
you Heather
hi I'm Katarina and those like Heather
Govan desperate to leave there's all of
us thinking well that's it we're gonna
go forward and now we're going to make
plans and how England's gonna go forward
as a country and the whole little hold
the UK and it just seems like the
Coronas just put a massive halt to all
of that at the moment scary you know all
sorts of bills I've got appeared know
for the van so if the obviously the
money stops coming in then then the
businesses probably and of dying
taxi drivers a thick bob was in the
minority in Sunderland he voted to
remain
there was a lot of heat in some land and
now we were talking about coronavirus
which actually has actually brought some
unity there a lot of people and brought
humanity but there's people who started
their care for the elderly and care for
their neighbors but for ZAF who's
self-employed that unity has come at a
cost
what upsets you most but a lot just
think this is stress of having to carry
on working where's it gonna lead I've
got a family to think about then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in a lockdown this is one way to party
[Applause]
[Music]
Nkosi Ennis is a wedding DJ but his
bookings have all been canceled so a
time on his hands and access to a roof
terrace he's putting on a short safe
rein people are going to be isolated
right now
and feeling really alone and so I think
that playing that kind of music where
everybody's jumping up and down together
without knowing people there you feel it
all of a sudden you feel like you're not
on the road we're living a time right
now where everything is about need and
necessity and things being essential so
although 15
of music and a balcony can seem a little
bit frivolous actually it's really
rather moving it just brings a little
bit of joy to a lot of people at a time
when that's exactly what they need
[Music]
[Applause]
katarina vote oxy reporting there while
the pressure to continue essential jobs
like food production and delivery comes
with an unseen cost for those trying to
support the nation in north wales our
correspondent Martha Kellner reports on
how their key workers are coping
the natural beauty of North Wales
attracts hundreds of thousands of
tourists each year that and the
country's rich history they speak one of
the oldest languages in Europe here but
this message was written with those from
over the border in mind many of the
people here are key workers and want to
be left alone to do their essential jobs
I'm driving to meet one of them
[Applause]
clears farm is near call when there's a
sheep farmer he's well practiced in
self-isolation every area of his
business is affected the price of land
he says has fallen off the claim and
fear has stopped taking guess whose
holiday rental property be let out we
have three or maybe four people asking
if he could come over Easter in the
beginning I was being quite nice to them
saying no we're on lockdown but by the
end I was telling them they're being bit
idiots
you can't believe that people are still
trying to no really no no it's
absolutely because believe me it's it's
I don't know what planet-- li-ion with
schools closed both these kids come to
work with him
in the chicken shed they bring new
meaning to the term egg hunts only on
weekends but they're here okay
the soaring demand for eggs is another
notable quirk of the lockdown it's gone
through fear and we can't produce enough
people staying home wanting to think
it's been a slight positive to this
nightmare that within to get his produce
into the supermarkets clear relies on
delivery drivers been from car more than
share is one of them he's parked up at
the side of an industrial estate this
lorry cab belly two meters wide has
become his home he's moved in for fear
of bringing the coronavirus back to his
family through what's in here then
obviously bed area and then yeah you've
got obviously your bed there middle
Locker there is you microwave several
storage lockers fridge down there
another locker there we have for five
weeks the only contact been has had with
his girlfriend and three young kids is a
video call each day and a socially
distant drop off of laundry son Jasper
who was born ten weeks premature is just
three months old there must be a feeling
of intense loneliness oh yeah
when you're parked up in the middle of
nowhere eerily quiet you're alone with
your thoughts see your mind just goes
into overdrive of stuff and homesick I
think is the words you just you just
want to go home and then you start
oh I've missed this I've missed out is
there a limit to how many more weeks
months you would spend in there no for
me to keep my family safe
I'll go years ago after the calf and
Mauer viaducts provides a grand welcome
into Wrexham where Kelly sell this so
long two years ago but she hadn't
factored a global pandemic into the
business plan now she's using her son as
a her model for online tutorials the
message of me please help me I can do
videos like how how to do it from home
simply for you at the moment
hard hard it's a constant worry
did you know what you're getting in
terms of the government grammar if it be
made clear enough to you yeah so I meant
to be having like the 10 the 10 grand
grant it should be happening boy again
we just waiting should that just keep
you afloat depend on this lasts I'm
hoping you know it's not too long and
we're going to be all there's gonna be a
massive time you know heading to the
north coast of Wales and the beauty of
London no pier belies huge economic and
social strife I'm just driving along the
main seafront in London no it's a
stunning day usually it would be filled
with tourists but these B&Bs and hotels
are completely empty the staff that
usually work here are at home now some
of them furloughed some of them not
being paid at all it's what makes this
place so vulnerable not to the corona
virus itself but to the resultant
lockdown
experts predict Llandudno will be among
the 10 town's worse affected by the
economic impact of coronavirus and as
ever it's the poorest who will be hit
hardest
I meet John sat outside a supermarket
he's only home is a tenth in the hills
above the town notice you've got the
rainbow on your your stick yeah you know
long as it's don't support them you know
yeah has it been lonelier very yeah it's
a lonely life to live on the street yet
almost anything
yeah well both know this is happening
cuz there's that fear of of people
anyway yeah but what's here than me more
than anything you know she's you've also
do catch any and like that structurally
there's nothing but if those who do I
could nicely Michel just know where I
could go no way
I involve you know K you know Kalos well
we were talked in the car last night
here my husband Ren see and I see the
best I still have probably about trial
for seen people just went straight past
you when the husband versus what change
your big it's heartbreaking isn't it
particularly tongues like this are you
worried John London knows expected to be
one of the worst hit places in terms of
getting back on its feet to death I am
wooded [ __ ]
I'm on at universe declare they didn't
know I didn't know way I didn't either
way I can survive I can survive
John's desperation and uncertainty about
the future is mirrored across this
country
yeah from those making adjustments to
their daily lives to all those trying to
eke a positive from their situation
life goes on here it feels empty Martha
Kellner reporting there well social
distancing centered the vocabulary for a
practice unfamiliar to most people but
in Northern Ireland divisions between
close neighbors are not new our senior
Island correspondent David Levin's
reports on the barriers broken down to
fight a common enemy
there are two things that set Belfast
apart its dividing walls and the ability
of its people to see beyond them when
they have to behind the barriers some
have self isolated for decades Catholics
and Protestants on different sides now
facing the same threat coronavirus Jim
is an Irish Republican John comes from a
loyalist back right they are serving
together on the Simcoe vyd response team
we're both from different sides of the
community and we have a kid there and we
would give their that gear doesn't want
to stop and I think people are starting
to put all of that into perspective
[Music]
loyalists have halted the marching
season here they won't be gathering to
mark ancient victories on the 12th of
July religions nothing if we're both
caught were both bleed red ever broke
the contract covered 19 end up in
hospital religions nothing honest about
you know you two nests period it and
being proactive I'm using it as a as a
springboard to take ourselves forward
Sasha is a wedding photographer but
ceremonies are prohibited so she's been
capturing the lives of her neighbors
instead I've had people are pajamas have
had people in their socks and their
slippers have had people that have
dressed up for the occasion
and just really as they are today if I
look back on these are her doorstep
Diaries she's adopted the idea of a New
York photographer not for profit but to
lighten the mood and record history the
families as well themselves have all
been saying that it's something that
they are really grateful to have so
they'll be able to show their children
because a lot of children are saying
what's going on and sort of no one that
it's different
but it's not for a few years time but
they'll be able to appreciate like the
gravity of what was happening nine
it's perfect it's something that we're
probably never gonna experience ever
again so I feel it's really important
that something like this is documented
that we can look back on and years to
come even for our kids our kids to
remember this part of history and then
even for them to show their kids in
death as in life there's a new normal
Northern Ireland has complex funeral
rites and rituals normally centered on a
gathering called awake they're the
differences of our communities disappear
and people cry together they had health
stories and laugh and that's part of the
grieving process as well
ian has been an undertaker for 30 years
only once before had he overseen a
funeral with no family or clergy able to
attend given that the work is such a
fundamental aspect of our culture here
do you think Northern Ireland is
struggling with the loss of that more
than perhaps England Scotland and Wales
wilwayco much much more you know the
other thing is that it's it's a complete
community event and we're struggling
with it because we can't actually see
the person so we have no mental closure
on the person's death and that's what
the problem is decades of violence and
thousands of deaths left a legacy of
resilience in Northern Ireland people
here are adept at finding hope amid
adversity that's the spirit of a place
that punches way above its weight this
is game number one on the tee from
Northern Ireland Darren Clarke the sign
of summer at royal Portrush but the
course that hosted the open has been
forced to close Northern Ireland's
world-famous links in Lough die
nine months ago the eyes of the world
were on the causeway coast
the contrast between scenes at this
seaside resort could not be greater tens
of thousands of spectators made their
way here for the tournament and we're
overlooking the 18th green we're seeing
Aria was crying the champion golfer no
one imagined a day when play would be
halted by a pandemic cough it's bit of
an irrelevance at this time obviously
the the well-being of our members our
staff is at the forefront of our minds
but I think we have to look at the wider
world and you know our NHS staff and so
on on the issues that they're dealing
with the biggest names in golf dined on
the finest Northern Irish produce those
who did the catering for them faced a
very different challenge no ballet liske
farm would usually be producing artisan
cheese for the high-end market instead
they're delivering milk and other basic
necessities
we couldn't travel with them due to
government restrictions but shattered
they phone while they made their rhymes
Dean is this turning back the clock
whenever one personally I was a child
you know we used to have a milkman we
used to have a bread line we used to
have a fishmonger and the postman and
those were four people that you know
used to regularly call with you know
good quality food and this is exactly
the service of where we're trying to put
back on the map again from crafting
cheese for the royal family to
delivering milk to neighbors in
isolation that's life in lockdown for
this fifth generation farmer sometimes
it's the simplest things that matter
most
you